قال مراسل الجزيره ان قوات الاحتلال فجرت
منزل عائله الاسير اسامه بني فضل في بلده
عقربه جنوب نابلس وذلك بعد اقتحامها
البلده الواقعه جنوب نابلس واسامه بني فضل
هو منفذ هجوم حواره في شهر اغسطس الماضي
التي ادت الى مقتل مستوطنين اثنين كما
اقتحمت قريه كفر اللبد شرق
طولكرم
معنا من نابلس مراسل الجزيره محمد خيري
محمد لو تطلعنا على اخر
التطورات نعم مواجهات عنيفه في الحقيقه
دارت بين الشبان الفلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي اقتحمت قريه
عقربه جنوب مدينه نابلس خلال الساعه
الماضيه واطلقت القوات الاسرائيليه بكثافه
قنابل الغاز الب للدموع بجاه الشبان
الفلسطينيين وهو ما ادى بالتالي الى اصابه
اكثر من 15 شابا فلسطينيا بحالات اختناق
وفي بعض المناطق منعت القوات الاسرائيليه
سيارات الاسعاف من الوصول الى المصابين
القوات الاسرائيليه دهمت عددا من منازل
المواطنين الفلسطينيين وخاصه منزل عائله
الاسير اسامه بني فضل واخلت هذه المنازل
كما استدعت امام مسجد عمر بن الخطاب المق
لعائله الاسير وامرته بتفكيك شبابيك
المسجد واخلاء واغلاقه بشكل تام ثم فجرت
الطابق الثاني من وهو من عماره مكونه من
ثلاثه طوابق وهو منزل عائله الاسير اسامه
بني فضل و واثناء ذلك ايضا كما اشرنا داهم
تعدد من منازل المواطنين وكذلك حققت
ميدانيا مع عدد من الفلسطينيين تتهم
السلطات الاسرائيليه الاسير اسامه بني فضل
بتنفيذ عمليه حواره التي وقعت قبل عده
اشهر في مغسله للسيارات على الشارع
الرئيسي في بلده حواره وادت الى مقتل
مستوطنين اثنين يشار الى ان الاسير اسامه
بني فضل يبلغ من العمر 20 عاما وهو طالب
في كليه الهندسه الميكانيكيه في جامعه
النجاح في مدينه نابلس واعتقل في عمليه
معقده يمكن القول نفذها جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه
بعد قرابه 100 يوم على تنفيذ عمليه حواره
واستش في مخيم جنين كانت تلك العمليه
واستشهد خلالها خمسه شبان فلسطينيين
واعتقل الاسير اسامه بني فضل وهناك ايضا
في الضفه الغربيه عمليات اقتحام واسعه
لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في عدد من
المدن في هذه الاثناء وتتركز هذهه
العمليات في منطقه الخليل جنوبي الضفه
الغربيه ودارت مواجه بين الشبان
الفلسطينيين نعم انوه لهذا العجل مراسل
الجزيره افادنا عن ان قواه الاحتلال فجرت
منزل عائله الاسير اسامه بني فضل في بلده
عقربه جنوب نابلس على كل حال الوقت داهمنا
شكرا لك من نابلس مراس الجزيره محمد خيري